Speaker 1: Hey, this is very, very interesting. I
finally was able to get on truth, social. Truth.
Social is the Trumpian social media platform
that Trump seems unable to pronounce correctly
both. Central. Exactly. Truth central. I finally
was able to get on truth social because they now
you can just sign up on a desktop computer. You
don't need to have a particular phone now to do it
so you can find me on truth social at Pacman. I'm
just trolling on there. I'll probably get banned.
But I realized when looking around that on
Election Day, Tuesday, before and after the
election failed, former President Donald Trump was
engaged in just a dystopian authoritarian series
of screeds and posts. I don't know what they
don't call them tweets because it's not Twitter,
although they basically copied Twitter to design
the site. Check out the stuff that Donald Trump
was posting throughout the day and then after. So
Trump posting, remember all three candidates in
Pennsylvania were ultra maga. So what Trump was
doing there was hedging his endorsement. Trump
endorsed Mehmet Oz, and we still don't know who
actually won that primary. But Trump was trying to
basically say whether it's Dave McCormick or Kathy
Barnett or Mehmet Oz, it's all a win for Trump
because they're all ultra maga. So that was Trump
hedging earlier in the day. But then here's the
really scary post, as has happened before in other
elections, including with Donald Trump's in 2020.
We didn't have the results around 11 p.m. or
midnight Eastern on Election Day. And Donald
Trump posted two troth essential quote, Dr. Oz
should declare victory. It makes it much harder
for them to cheat with the ballots that they,
quote, just happened to find. And Trump's quote
and end full quote, that's an authoritarian
nightmare. And that is exactly. You know,
when we go back to Trump coming out at 2 a.m. on
Election Day in November of 2020 and saying we won
when he very clearly hadn't won, it wasn't clear
he lost, but it was very clear he hadn't yet won.
He's admitting what the game is here. You say you
won. You just take credit for it and it makes it
harder than it poisons the well where people say,
I don't know. I mean, he claimed victory. He must
have won. Trump then attacking Fox News, saying
Fox News had a really bad night. They were way off
on the count and timing in the Oz vote. Anybody
watching would have said it was over when actually
it was just the opposite. I assumed the coverage
was being led by the same guy that called Arizona,
who, believe it or not, they brought back. I
want his agent now. Of course, Trump continues
to insist that he actually won Arizona. It is not
true. Joe Biden won Arizona. Joe Biden won Arizona
by any measure of how you count ballots.
And Trump continues to lie about that.
And then Trump posting another one of
these truths which are actually lies
quite Kafkaesque quote The fake news media is
having a really time, really hard time saying
that MAGA and Trump didn't have anything but
a spectacular evening of voting and winning.
Hold on. The best is yet to come. Now, of
course, Madison Cawthorn lost after just
six months in office. Some Trumpists won, some
Trumpists lost. But understand that the game is
endorsed. Mostly people who we know are going
to win with or without Trump's endorsement
and then take credit for it. It is a nightmare.
Untruth, social. If you're curious, it's sort of
masochistic. I get it. But if you're curious,
I'm on there. At least until they banned me.
I'm deep. Hackman on truth.
Speaker 3: Truth, truth.
Speaker 1: Yeah, exactly. We'll take a
quick break and be right back after this.